i i do i do want to watch more films
it's been weird seeing films
released online on like hbo max i like
it
and stuff like that right yeah i think
it's it's
just reaffirmed for me that i just love
the movie theater and i love the
experience and
i hope that it never goes away no it's
great like i love going to it but it's
like
i'm not like you where i can just watch
anything like that it needs to be a
movie that i wanted
i just enjoy the atmosphere so much that
i will go and watch anything
i i i feel like there are some movies
that i would prefer to watch in movie
theaters than
others like sorry tennis
maybe actually i i feel like that would
that would that would have been cool in
the movie theaters but
like any action flick i feel like would
be better in the movie
like i feel like i missed out on
something not watching those [ __ ] car
scenes antenna where they're like
[ __ ] going back in time and
zooming forward it was so good in the
theater it was amazing
i need to watch it this way it's so good
dude it's it's it's good just just for
the visuals
because it's by far one of the most
visually
interesting interesting like films i've
ever seen super interesting yeah
but yeah i mean i i want to watch more
movies i i just
i just really can't watch movies at home
because i i put it on i see that [ __ ]
two hour thing counting down
i'm like oh that's a long time
that's a long time to focus damn right
to me it's like
an hour and a half youtube video yeah to
me it's
i don't know something about a movie and
it's it's the commitment
like once i've put a movie on i'll i'll
[ __ ] watch it
but it's it's it's bringing myself to
it's
willing myself to even put that movie on
in the first place that i find trouble
with
yeah i'm like i think to myself i'm like
all right i can watch this movie
like an hour and a half but at the same
time i could also watch like
three 30-minute youtube videos
i could do that i think i might prefer
that i could just watch random youtube
videos for an hour and a half yeah i
don't really care about it i could watch
like
second meme clips on youtube
i've been doing a lot of that recently
oh my god i mean that's because that's
all that's been coming up on my
recommended
i don't know what's going on with
youtube recently but they just stopped
recommending youtube videos and started
recommending youtube
like yeah like twitter videos yeah legit
it's so weird
if if i get a recommendation nowadays
and it's like above a minute i'm like oh
this must be a [ __ ] special video
oh okay the one we watch before we start
recording the chunk challenge
that's my that's my favorite video it's
been recommended recently it's brilliant
but it's gotten to the point now where
like even all the comment sections can
all agree on what
like everyone's everyone's got
recommended the same playlist because
everyone's quoting the same videos even
though
they're like they're quoting a different
video on a different meme video
and everyone gets a reference even
though it's not on any kind of playlist
yeah well it's like people watch two
hours of trash taste
and not like no movie for me two hour
trash taste podcast
let's go it's like oh wow okay thank you
i'm honored yeah thanks
did you guys used to watch more movies
back in the day oh 100
yeah yeah when i was like 15 i loved it
but that's when you discover like that
you can watch things online yeah
well she could tell me can watch any
movie i want by just typing the name and
the google
what the [ __ ] are you for real that was
like a massive revelation in my life i
was like oh my god
did you guys through go through that
imdb top 100 movie phase oh yeah
top 250 movie phase yeah right you're
not
you know what the first movie ever i've
watched illegally was what
it was like the hannah montana movie
how do you remember this i just remember
that was when i discovered that you
could watch it is that the one where
it's like
the best of both worlds i think so i
don't know what it was but i remember
it's like the one was just on tour or
some [ __ ] yeah there was like a dance to
it as well
yeah yeah cause i remember i remember
that someone kept walking up and getting
up in front of the camera
for the movie i was one of those
well the way to see is the thing right
this is like the more you get older the
more you have money
the your your tolerance for the the
quality
so when you first when you're like 12
you watch anything
for some reason you're like people
standing up in front of the camera
shaky cam quality no problem i'll watch
it
at the moment you get like a hd dvd you
rip your light i can't go back
it's like would you like 480p i'm
excited why isn't it shaking why is that
no artifact why
yeah they still do that now right